if you are looking for a sign to go to
the hospital this may just be it my name
is Dr Jordan Wagner and I'm a board
certified emergency medicine physician
with a YouTube channel called Dr ER and
of course if you think you are
experiencing a true emergency please
call 9-1-1 or your country's emergency
equivalent and or get to the hospital
immediately if you are still unsure if
you are experiencing a true medical
emergency never fear I put together a
list of five reasons that you or someone
you love should get to the hospital
number five trouble breathing do huffing
and puffing having a difficult time
breathing suddenly wheezing or having
any kind of out of the blue shortness of
breath you may want to have 9-1-1 on
speed dial because this sudden onset of
shortness of breath May indicate
something much more serious that
requires immediate medical attention
definitely get to an emergency room if
this is the case as an ER doc when I
hear a patient is having a sudden onset
of trouble breathing there is a laundry
list of medical conditions editions that
could cause this that need to be ruled
out especially the bad ones things like
having a heart attack blood clot in the
lungs problems with your aorta and other
lung problems like collapsed lung asthma
complications chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease or COPD heart failure
infections in the Airways like croup
bronchitis pneumonia the list goes on
and on not to scare you but trouble
breathing is very serious and we need to
rule out the potential life-threatening
causes for your sudden shortness of
breath in normal level of oxygen in the
body is usually 95 or higher but if your
oxygen levels drop below 90 to 95
percent or you just feel uncomfortable
and are having trouble catching your
breath definitely get to the hospital
now I repeat definitely go to the
hospital number four reason you should
go to the emergency department chest
pain if you have chest pain that lasts
longer than five minutes and doesn't go
away even when you rest or take
medication and you're still having this
pain this could be an issue especially
if you find that your chest pain is
paired with shortness of breath cold
sweats nausea fatigue lightheadedness or
any other pain that radiates out to the
body parts like your arms for instance
your chest pain could be due to things
like a heart attack coronary occlusion
in aortic dissection and aortic aneurysm
rib injury anxiety among many other
serious life-threatening issues if you
or one of your loved ones thinks they
can just ignore their sudden onset of
chest pain or quote work through it
don't be that person please get to the
emergency department number three reason
displaced or open wound fractures
fractures in doctors speak just means
broken and displaced fractures can
either be open or closed when you break
a bone the skin is sometimes intact AKA
close fracture or if the bone breaks
through the skin that in doctors speak
is called an open fracture but no matter
what you call it if you break something
in your body or or have a suspicion you
or someone you love broke a bone seek
medical attention right away then we'll
decide whether you need to have it
splinted sling it or whether you may
require a reduction procedure or surgery
to put the bones back in place it's also
important to get checked out because you
want to make sure that the displaced
bone isn't doing anything bad like
cutting off the blood supply somewhere
or pinching a nerve for that incident
and it's also important for pain
management even if you don't really have
pain now not properly taking care of a
bone fracture can cause major issues
down the line get treated today and
you'll minimize things like growth and
Shooters arthritis osteoporosis and
other pain in the future have you ever
broken a bone let me know which one and
let me know what your experience was
like in the comments below number two
reason you go to the emergency
department sudden numbness or weakness
numbness in the body usually happens
when there's a lack of blood supply to
an area nerve compression or even nerve
damage kind of feels like pins and
needles in your body that sudden feeling
or numbness can also result from
infection inflammation trauma and other
life-threatening issues like a stroke if
this is happening to you or someone you
know pay close attention if you feel
numbness particularly that is occurring
on just one side of your body you need
to get to the ER immediately certainly
there are other neurologic conditions
that may cause numbness but my concern
when I hear sudden numbness or weakness
on one side of the body is always strong
this is very serious and could be
potentially life-threatening Strokes are
the number five cause of death in the
United States they can occur when a
blood vessel that carries oxygen and a
nutrients to the brain is either blocked
by a clot or Burst when this happens
blood and oxygen can't get to that area
of the brain and the brain cells start
to die so to avoid further complications
or other potentially disabling outcomes
if you feel numbness or weakness in your
body play it safe and call 9-1-1 or seek
immediate medical attention number one
reason to go to the emergency department
anything you're concerned about
sometimes serious medical issues aren't
that obvious maybe your symptoms are a
little vague or maybe someone is telling
you to just write it out say a sudden
onset headache especially if someone is
on blood thinners seizure sudden
inability to speak or walk or move Sun
drooping on one side of the body pain in
your arm or your jaw car accident
kitchen knife accident anything at all
that seems suspicious or on the opposite
end of the spectrum symptoms or pain
that just comes on out of the blue
that's what we call acute symptoms they
just pop up and cause a person a sudden
pain and discomfort this could be your
body's sign that it's telling you it's
time to seek medical attention here's
what it all boils down to the symptoms
that I've listed out are not a complete
listing but rather an overview or
guideline to try and help you assess
whether you or your loved one is at risk
is it better to get to the emergency
department and be wrong long but had the
reassurance that the symptoms were not
life-threatening then completely ignore
the symptoms and put yourself at risk
believe me I've seen people sort of
ignore their symptoms and the situation
turns out to be a lot more dire than
they originally thought headaches that
turned out to be brain bleeds or an
allergy and shortness of breath symptoms
that turn out to be a heart attack all
the time I see this in the emergency
department so give yourself the peace of
mind and either reach out to your health
care provider call 9-1-1 for an
ambulance or get to the hospital
immediately if you have any of these
symptoms I've mentioned alright that's
been a quick breakdown of some of the
signs you should go to the ER certainly
there are a ton more if you want me to
do a follow-up video to these please hit
that like button and let me know in the
comments I have a lot of valuable
information when it comes to emergency
medicine then I cannot wait to share
with you and hopefully it takes some of
the fear and the unknown out of the
medicine so that way you can be a better
advocate for your own health but let me
know in the comments if you've ever made
a trip to the emergency department and
what was that experience like for you
shout out to nucleus medical media for
their awesome video library and Graphics
this video was a collaboration between
them and my doctor ER YouTube channel
subscribe to both channels thank you so
much for watching and stay healthy my
friend